[Music]  free oxygen is not readily available on  mars fortunately tons and tons of oxygen  on mars in the form of carbon dioxide in  its atmosphere so we have this machine  called moxie that's going to go up on  the next curiosity rover in 2020 it'll  collect co2 from the martian atmosphere  strip off the carbon and release the  oxygen nasa intends to build the same  machine 100 times bigger or to have 100  times the capacity and actually to  situate it on the surface of mars at  least two years before astronauts land  on mars and have it make oxygen for two  years and store it in tanks to be used  both as fuel and both as something that  astronauts can breathe